The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
What I'm going to
be talking about
is some of the
fundamental work that
has been done
trying to understand
neural basis for memory
and spatial perception
and cognition that comes
largely from behavioral and
electrophysiological studies
in the brain system that's
shown here-- the hippocampus.
And as I was mentioning
before we started,
this year's Nobel
Prize was given
to John O'Keefe, who
discovered the properties
of individual neurons
in the hippocampus
by applying these
methods for recording
the discharge of
single cells by putting
little wires into the brain--
so-called extracellular
recordings.
You put in a wire.
The tip of the electrode can
record electrical discharge
of cells.
You measure the
discharge of cells
as animals move around in space.
And you try to figure out what
this part of the brain does.
Now where the observation
part of science
comes in in this
case is interesting,
because it relates to another
aspect of neuroscience.
And that is the relationship
between the neurobiology
and behavior.
And this is an approach known
as a neuroethological approach.
And that's studying
the brain systems
in the context in which they
actually evolve and were used.
And so that could apply
to the use of song
as a mechanism of
communication in birds.
It can come from
the finding prey
in the dark, when it comes
sound-localization owls.
In the case of rodents,
O'Keefe appreciated the fact
that the hippocampus
in rodents really
has a primary role in
spatial navigation--
that animals that have
damaged the hippocampus
have problems with
spatial navigation.
And the hippocampus
had been studied up
to that point using animals
that were head-fixed.
So you take a little rat.
You fix his head.
And the reason for
fixing its head
is for convenience,
largely, so that when
you place these little
electrodes into the brain,
the animal doesn't move.
They don't move.
Electrode moves, you
can't get good recordings.
So you need to keep
the preparation fixed.
So you fix the animal's head.
Then you figure out
ways to actually
look, to study the system
given the constraints
of the methodology.
And that involved, largely,
before John O'Keefe in 1970,
using methods of
classical conditioning.
So you might be familiar
with basic learning theory.
And how do we learn
how to do things?
Well, it's basically
chaining together
stimulus response associations.
You see something,
you do something,
you get rewarded for doing that.
You're more likely to do
that again in the future.
This is a basic
Pavlovian conditioning.
I ring a bell, you get food.
You associate bell
with the food.
And so that was the thinking--
that all of cognition
can be built up from basic
stimulus-response associations.
But there was a
movement around the time
that O'Keefe was
doing this work that
proposed that that
was insufficient--
that simple behavioral simple
stimulus response learning was
insufficient, that
there was some kind
of internal foundation upon
which learning was applied.
And this was the
so-called cognitive theory
of learning and memory.
And the hippocampus
was posited beta-site
of one property of
this cognitive learning
as applied to space.
And the observation was
actually a fairly simple one.
If you take a rat--
I see you want to
learn something.
That is, if you want to learn
to associate a cue with food
or you want to train it to go
over and press a lever for food
or-- you want it
to learn something,
and you do this
in an environment
and put it in a box.
Well, if you take a rat
and you put it in that box,
let's say, the day before,
and just let it wander around.
It does nothing.
It just explores space.
You take it out.
And now we take two rats-- one
that's been in the box before
and one that has not
been in the box before--
and the rat that
has been in the box
before will learn faster
than the animal has not
been in the box.
And you say, why would just
passive exposure to that box
enhance it's learning?
And this phenomena is
known as latent learning.
The animal had learned
something that it could then
apply to this new learning even
though it was not instructive.
It wasn't rewarded for doing
anything, it just explored.
And so this idea that there was
some sort of latent capacity
to enhance learning
was motivated
the study of the
hippocampus in the context
of non-head-fixed recording.
And so it keeps real inside.
In fact, the paper that was
cited for the Nobel Prize
was the paper in which he first
recorded from these cells--
and all he did was just take
the animals out of the ear bars.
So he took the animal
out of the ear bars
and just let it run around on
a tabletop, just like this,
actually.
It was a table at the
University College
London about this size where
the rat just kind of wandered
around.
And he made observations-- oh,
here's a cell that fires when
the animal goes over
to the left hand side--
very descriptive,
but the key insight
was to study the
hippocampus when rats are
doing what rats normally do--
explore in space.
So it was this
ethological approach.
And what he discovered was that
cells in the hippocampus.--
and this is a cross-section.
The hippocampus is found here.
It's in the medial
temporal lobes.
The name hippocampus comes
from the Greek for seahorse,
so in humans, it sort of
looks like a seahorse.
The regions here--
the terminology CA,
these different fields
of the hippocampus,
comes from cornu
ammonis, or Amman's horn.
That's because it looks
like a ram's horn.
So if you think about it,
it's like little ram's horns
right here, put them
in the temporal lobes
and you move them
in there, that's
where your hippocampus is.
Just like this.
And if you make a cross-section,
slice through that,
this is the circuit.
So information comes in
from across the brain,
converges in the primary
input to the hippocampus--
that's called entorhinal cortex,
which is what the other Nobel
Prize was awarded to--
the husband and wife team that
had discovered and identified
the properties of cells
in the entorhinal cortex,
these so-called grid cells
that seem to carry information
about actual, it seemed
like, Cartesian-like spatial
information conveyed
in the hippocampus.
So stuff comes in from the
rest of the brain, converges
in the entorhinal cortex,
and then goes around
this little loop, from these
three primary subfields--
the dentate gyrus, CA cornu
ammonis 3, CA1, subiculum,
and back on again.
So it goes through this loop.
Classically, it had
been referred to
as the trisynaptic loop.
One synapse, dentate, CA3,
CA1, and then back out.
And again, recordings in
this part of the hippocampus
reveal the properties
which I'll mention,
and that is that the cells
respond to locations in space.
But prior to that--
this electrophysiological
work in rodents--
there had been human
neuropsychological work,
in particular the seminal
case of the patient HM who
had been studied
here for many decades
before he just
recently passed away.
Known as HM, or Henry Molaison,
as he is sort of recently
revealed to be a patient who had
undergone bilateral resection
of medial temporal lobes.
Cut out parts of his
hippocampus and other
associated medial
temporal lobe structures
to treat intractable epilepsy.
He subsequently lost the ability
to form any new memories.
So had permanent
anterograde- couldn't
form any new memories going
forward in the future and lost
some of his older memories.
So you lose memories
in humans, rodents
can't navigate in space, also
humans have a spatial deficit,
so there's some connection
between space and memory.
And the question
is, what is that?
What would link spatial
navigation and memory?
But not just any
kind of memory--
what we refer to as
episodic memory-- memory
for events or experiences.
And so the working hypothesis
is that these two things
are really connected by a
need, a computation imperative,
to maintain information
about time order.
And that is, if you're
going to use experience
to guide future
behavior, you need
to figure out what the
causal relationships are
between events in the world.
If I see A and B, what I
really want to figure out--
I don't just want
to record the fact
that A and B happen together.
Ultimately, I want
to try to understand
the relationship between
A and B. Did A cause B,
or how might I actually
predict B given A?
And the way I
would do that would
be to construct some kind
of simple internal model,
a predictive model, that's
based on experience.
And so the idea is, hippocampus
captures experience,
and then sort through
some process, which we'll
refer to as the process
of consolidation,
translates experience into
some working model that
can predict events and can
be used to guide behavior
in decision making.
And critical to that
is just the idea
of time and a
particular time order.
So as I mentioned, the use
of very simple technology,
in this case extracellular
neurophysiological recording--
taking a tiny wire-- this wire
is actually four small wires,
each one about 10
microns across.
You twist them together
in a little bundle.
The bundle is about 35 microns.
Human hair is on the order of
typically about 50 microns,
so these are wires, or
multi contact electrodes,
about as large as a human hair.
We thread these things
through the little oil rig
drilling device here, which is--
these little micromanipulators
allow this wire
to be driven down through
very small guide cannula,
and so out the bottom
will be a number
of these independent
individual electrodes,
each controlled by their
own micromanipulator.
So we can send these
electrodes down--
this entire device,
in this case,
weighs anywhere
from 12 to 20 grams,
and this can be placed
on an animal's head
permanently or chronically, and
that is that once it goes on,
it doesn't come off.
So they will have this
little helmet like thing
on their head, a small
opening is made in the skull,
the wires are sent through, and
the whole surgical procedure
takes maybe 30 to 45 minutes.
It's like an outpatient thing.
It would probably
take longer to have
your wisdom teeth pulled than to
have a brain implant installed.
But then once this is
installed, these electrodes
can be driven down and
placed permanently.
It gives you the ability
to monitor pattern activity
across large populations
over long periods of time--
days, weeks, months.
So you have tapped into
activity in this brain area,
and you can monitor as animals
experience, learn, and recall.
This is what the
raw data looks like.
This is a cartoon of the
electrode with four contacts.
The idea with the
four contacts is
it gives you the ability
to triangulate location,
much as you stereoscopically
can determine depth.
These four contacts
will give you
the ability to
triangulate things
in three dimensional space.
One of the properties of this
hippocampal circuit, and that
is-- so this little
cross-section-- you
imagine a neuron here.
And so there are
going to be, again,
neurons distributed
across the hippocampus.
In the rat, there are on
the order of maybe 200,000
cells in area CA1.
In the entire hippocampus,
there are on the order of one
to two million cells.
And if you drop an electrode
any place into the hippocampus,
you will find cells that have
this kind of spatial property.
And so what that says is
that spatial information
is distributed not
in a topographic way.
In other words, it's not
one location in space
is mapped into one location
in the hippocampus.
Unlike some of the sensory
areas that have this kind
of topography, for instance,
if you record in the visual
cortex, where there was there
would be some correspondence
between location
and visual field,
and the location of cells in
the cortex that respond to that
so-called retinotopic mapping--
visual field mapped
onto the anatomy.
Same thing with the
somatosensory system.
As I move and I touch
different parts of the body,
the cells that respond to
that will be mapped out
in a largely one-to-one
correspondence
between the adjacency of
stimuli in the input space
and adjacency of
the representation
in the neural space that does
not occur in the hippocampus.
Two cells that are right
next to one another
are no more likely to respond
to nearby locations in space
than two cells that are
distant from one another.
So, as we'll discuss,
the principle
of information representation
in the hippocampus
appears to be one of kind of
sparse distributed patterning,
that you have lots of
cells that will respond
to different environments
and individual cells
don't have a unique
relationship to locations.
It's really the pattern
across cells that gives you
a unique signature of code.
We're taking
advantage of the fact
that you don't necessarily
have to place the electrodes
at the proper place in
order to get responses
in some location in space.
Anywhere you put these
electrodes in the hippocampus,
you're going to get
a certain fraction--
generally about 30% of
the cells will respond
in the given environment.
And this is what those
responses look like.
I won't go through the technical
details, but, needless to say,
this just shows
how events, action
potentials that are detected--
in here, you see a voltage
trace, you pick out
the amplitude of these little
voltage transients generated
by action potentials
in the cells,
you plot the amplitude across
these different channels.
In this way, each point
is an action potential,
and what you see is that
the amplitudes will cluster
in a way that reflect
the relative position
or location of cells--
the sources relative
to these wires,
using the basic principle that
if you're closer to a wire,
the signal is going
to get stronger.
So amplitude is essentially
inversely related to distance.
So here, this is the amplitude
of an action potential plot
across two channels.
These points are
larger on channel one,
small on channel 2.
That means it's close to
channel 1, far from channel 2.
And then different cells will
have different relations.
This will be large on channel 2,
small on channel 1, et cetera.
So you can figure out where
these cells are in space,
means you can pick out lots
of cells from, in this case,
maybe 12 to 18 electrodes
can give you 50
to 100 or more cells.
And then looking at the
activity of those cells
in a simple box--
this is just a little box, one
wall removed, little ceiling
of cubes, simple
architectural design,
nice, clean and simple--
what you get is clean and simple
mapping of spatial locations
into these neural responses.
So each one of these panels
represents the activity
of individual cells.
So this is about 80
simultaneously recorded cells.
The color of the heat map
indicates the firing rate
of these individual cells.
Red indicates high firing
rate, blue indicates no firing.
So this is a top down
view of that box.
So this cell, for instance, when
the animal is wandering around
in the box, the cell is
silent in all the blue areas,
and when it goes in the
lower right hand corner,
the cell fires vigorously.
So silent, fires vigorously.
This one fires on
the left hand wall.
This one also fires on
the lower right hand side.
So this points out the
combinatorial nature
of this spatial
representation, and that
is that if the animal is
in the lower right hand
corner of this
particular box, we'll
get these two cells to fire.
If I take the animal and I
put it into a different box,
all of these responses
will be scrambled up.
There's nothing that
says this cell will
fire in the lower right
hand corner of another box.
And certainly, even if it does
fire in the lower right hand
corner, this other cell isn't
going to fire along with it.
And at any given location,
there are roughly 1% to 5%
of the cells that are firing.
So at any given location, there
are about maybe 5,000 cells
in the hippocampus
that are active.
So the unique location and
unique context and environments
can be conveyed across a unique
pattern of about 5,000 cells
out of 100,000 or 200,000 cells.
So there's large
combinatorial space
in which one can represent
unique locations or potentially
even unique experiences
within different locations.
You see that many
cells are silent.
On average, about
30% of the cells
respond in any
given environment.
The silent cells,
as we'll see, they
can be detected when the
animals are not in a running
around or experiencing space,
but when they're asleep
or in these other
offline states,
when the hippocampus is actually
thinking about other stuff.
We'll talk about that a bit.
And then here, you can also see
a small number of these cells.
In this case, about 5%
to 10% of these cells
seem to have elevated firing
rate across the entire space.
These are actually a
different class of neurons.
These are excitatory neurons.
These are inhibitory neurons.
The inhibition,
the idea that you
have circuits that can
both excite and inhibit,
and that this is used
as a circuit property
to sculpt computation
is something
that we'll also discuss.
So there's balance between
excitation as kind of a circuit
principle that's used.
Inhibitory cells fire
all over the place.
They're not really
communicating information.
They're really modulating the
processing of information.
And another property
of these cells
that O'Keefe termed
place cells is that when
animals are constrained to move
along these limited paths--
in this case, this is a linear
track, as we refer to it.
It's like a little
corridor, and it
was moving down this corridor.
When they move down a
corridor, cells don't only
fire where the animal is, but
also in the direction that it's
going.
And so this is the
first indication
these cells are not just--
again, it's not just a GPS.
It's not telling
you where you are.
It's at least telling
you where you're
going, maybe what you're doing.
So here, if I look
at this yellow cell,
I can tell that the animal
is not only in this location,
but it's moving down this
linear track in this direction.
So there's going to be a unique
sequence when the animal walks
along this path--
yellow cell, red
cell, green cell.
So the different cells
are color coded here.
So if you look over
time, you'll see
that there will be a
unique sequence of activity
in the hippocampus that reflects
the animal's actual behavior
experienced in that space.
So here, this is just a
little movie that shows raw--
this is what you would
actually see if you're
running the experiment.
This is a little top down view.
The green circle just highlights
where the rat actually is.
The color coding--
these are the cells
that we're picking up over here.
This is data as it would
be coming out of a set up.
You see, this light
blue cell fires here,
the dark blue cell fires here.
Dark blue cell, light blue cell.
So this is the spatial
firing property, place cells.
So the animal has stopped.
The one thing you will notice--
you saw lots of activity,
and animal stopped there, there
was this big burst of activity.
He'll stop again a
little bit later.
Now he's moving.
Now when he's moving ,
if you listen carefully,
you'll hear that there's
this background rhythm.
There's a modulation
that's going ch-ch-ch-ch.
Background modulation
activity which
is associated with locomotion.
So there are really two modes--
you're actively engaged or when
you're taking information in,
you get this rhythm.
When you're inattentive, not
engaged, not taking information
in, but internally
evaluated, the rhythm
goes away and is replaced
by these bursts of activity.
And so these two modes,
active attentive--
you're processing information
coming in, inattentive--
you're evaluating information,
you're thinking about stuff--
can be reflected in these two
characteristic modes, which
you can literally hear.
You can hear the
difference between the two.
Obviously, I've been listening
to these things for a long time
so it's very easy
for me to pick up.
It might be harder for you but,
you listen to it a little bit
and it's very easy to
distinguish these two
different brain routes.
So this is going to be
another view of that data.
So same data, only now, instead
of showing you the raw data,
where is the firing.
And that's one thing about this
correlate that's so compelling.
That was literally raw
data as it was coming out.
There's no processing at all
and you could see the correlate,
you can see the spatial
correlate, which tells you,
this is not something
that requires
I have to do
multiple regressions,
and show you all of the--
give you some sort of
statistical confidence
that this is what the
hippocampus is doing.
You can literally see
it in individual cells.
The spatial correlate is
extremely robust, compelling,
and consistent.
Those cells weren't selected.
If you record any of the
cells in the hippocampus,
they're all doing that.
The estimate is that over
95% of the cells that you
can record in rodent
hippocampus will
have these spatial properties.
So it's really a fundamental
property of this memory system.
So this is the same
data, except now,
instead of showing
the spiking, we're
going to use this simple
Bayesian Estimation
Algorithm to ask the question.
"OK, if we know which
cells are firing,
can we guess the location that
the animal would likely be?"
That is, if we know the firing
as a function of location,
we can use a Bayesian inference
to guess the probability
of location, given firing.
And that's what we're
going to do here.
Just asking, if we know
which cells are firing--
for instance, if the
blue cell is firing,
you would say, "Oh, the
animal's probably over here."
So recording across, looking
at pattern across many cells,
and then we're coming up
every 100 milliseconds,
we're coming up
with a probability
that that pattern could have
occurred if the animal was
at any location on this track.
And the probability is going
to be shown by a triangle.
Big triangle means
high probability.
And what you'll see is,
when we do this estimation,
when the animal's moving,
you see the triangle.
The triangles are
only highly probable
when the animal is
actually moving,
and only at the location
that the animal is.
So the hippocampus
is centrally--
the hippocampus
representation is
tracking the location the animal
and also when the animal stops.
Now, if you listen,
you heard the burst
and you look at the triangle,
when the animal stops,
the triangle no
longer corresponds
to where the animal is.
In fact, when you
get the burst, you
see the triangle jumping
around the track.
So again, there's
these two modes
and the representations
have these two properties.
Moving, oscillation,
track current location.
Stopping, oscillation goes
away, representation now
jumps across the track.
And interestingly, these
little bursts, like that,
also occur, not just when
the animal stops briefly,
but when it actually
goes to sleep.
So here on the inset,
this is the animal now
has been taken off
the track altogether.
It's just sitting in a
little box somewhere else,
it's curled up, and it's asleep.
You get these same bursts
and when you decode activity,
you find you can decode
the position on the track
and, if you look carefully, you
see that the position actually
follows a sequence of
trajectory along the track.
And we'll go into that in
a little bit more detail.
So you think of there being
these two states, the offline
and the online.
And the online, when
the animal's moving,
the characteristic mode of
activity in the hippocampus
is an oscillatory mode,
described as the theta rhythm,
which is this 10
hertz oscillation.
When the animal
stops and becomes
quiet and immobile, within
about half a second,
oscillation goes
away and is replaced
by these large transient
aperiodic events,
these so-called
sharp waves, because
in the extracellular
electrical field
that you measure, you see
these large deflections.
And then, if you zoom in--
I'll also show you shortly--
you can actually see that
these very high frequency
oscillations, about 100 to 200
hertz, riding on top of that,
these are referred
to as, ripples.
And this is the term that
Gyorgy Buzsaki came up with.
He described this sharp
wave ripple activity
as corresponding to this
offline state, quiet wakeful,
and some sleep states.
So the first thing is to look
at this oscillatory state.
So an animal's actually moving.
And I've already shown you the
spatial correlate, these place
cells.
But there's another
property of these cells
that O'Keefe also discovered.
But this was in early
1990s, around 1991.
And that is, he
noted, if you actually
look at the discharge of
single spikes with respect
to this oscillation,
first of all,
the spikes are
actually phase locked.
In other words, here
spikes fire when
the oscillation, this theta
rhythm, is at its peak.
So the idea is, this
oscillation really
reflects time
varying excitability,
sometimes where
cells likely to fire,
other times when it's not.
And you can think of this
oscillation in excitability
as being an oscillation
in relative excitability,
or inhibitions.
So inhibition, elevation
is high, it's low,
its high, it's low.
When inhibition is
low, cell fires.
When it's high,
cell doesn't fire.
So this is modulation
excitability.
You see this here.
But he noted another
thing, and that
is, if you look at
the precise phase--
so here, yes, cells tend
to fire at the peak,
but here, this is now
over time, but animal
moving at constant
velocity, space, and time,
are interchangeable.
So as the animal's moving
through it's place field,
the spikes start to fire earlier
and earlier, as this phase
code, spatial location.
So you can tell, based
upon the relative phase,
whether the animal is just
entering the field, spikes fire
late, here close to the
peak, versus further
into the field, where they
fire a little bit earlier.
There's a relationship
between distance
into the field and
relative phase.
What he termed,
phase precession.
And this is a
representation of that.
This is actual data.
This is just a cartoon
that illustrates
the basic principle.
And so the idea that,
if I have a place cell,
if I look at the
marginal distribution
as a function of location,
this would be the place field.
Otherwise, it would just
collapse all of this.
This is the spiking now, as a
function of position and phase.
If I just look at spiking
as a function of position,
as just the density of
firing, what I would get
is a place field.
Not many spikes here as the
animal enters the field, lots
of spikes here as
you get into-- this
would be the classic
spatial receptive field.
But now, if I introduce
phase, as well, now you say,
"Oh, wait, there's a
systematic relationship as well
between phase and location."
In fact, phase is a better
predictor of relative location
than firing rate.
If I asked, when
did the spike occur?
If it occurred
here, late in phase,
then I know the animal is
just entering the field.
If it occurs early
in phase, I know
it's at the end of its field.
And that's interesting.
And this is a simple
model that says, well,
an easy way of explaining
that is, if you just
have this excitability model--
and this was one
of the questions
that I guess you asked about
this sweeping inhibition.
So if we just imagine
that you have an input,
excitatory input, shown in blue,
and then an inhibitory input,
shown in red, where the
inhibition is oscillating,
and you apply a very
simple biophysical model
that says, a spike
action potential is
going to occur when
excitation and blue exceeds
inhibition and red.
More excitation inhibition,
you get a spike.
So here, in this oscillation,
anywhere the red trace
is higher than the
blue trace, no spiking.
So in this case, when
excitation is low,
you have to wait until
inhibition drops all the way
to here to get a spike.
This is late-phase.
So weak excitation
means you have
to wait until inhibition is low.
So this is the
sweeping inhibition,
you have to wait until it's low.
When excitation is strong, I
don't have to wait so long.
It can fire earlier.
So the principle here is
that there is a relationship
between magnitude and latency.
Stronger means earlier.
That's the
biophysical principle.
Very simple.
Stronger earlier, weaker later.
That will give you this
phase precession property.
Phase precession,
you might think
of as this
biophysical curiosity.
But when you think
about how that
would apply when you have more
than one place cell-- in fact,
I have two place cells here,
one in blue, one here in purple,
where place cell one is to
the left of place cell two.
So as the animal's
going through here,
first the blue cell will fire,
and then, the purple cell
will fire.
And if you look
at the excitatory
drive, shown here as a ramp
in blue, ramp in purple,
and now you ask,
"When is the blue cell
going to fire, and the
purple going to fire,
during each one of these
oscillatory cycles?"
The answer will be, well,
because the blue's-- the
excitatory drives the blue cells
higher than the purple cell,
blue is always going
to fire before purple.
In fact, in each
and every cycle,
it will be blue purple
blue purple blue purple.
So this principle
of phase precession,
or phase coding,
for single cells,
actually gives you sequential
encoding across a population
that you will actually
on each and every cycle
have a sequence.
The code in the hippocampus
is not a location,
it's actually a
sequence, a trajectory.
This is just raw
data, but I'm going
to quickly go-- this is
just talking about what
the spiking looks like.
And you can see,
if you look at it,
you see these spike sequences.
But the property's more
clearly demonstrated
when I do this decoding.
So what I'm showing you here--
this is, again, raw data.
But now, instead of
showing the spiking,
I'm showing you that
the result of doing
this decoding, this Bayesian
decoding, where there's
a probability estimate
that given spiking activity
in each one of a
set of successive 20
millisecond windows--
so I'm walking
along, now I'm firing
at a finer temporal resolution
every 20 milliseconds.
I'm doing the same
decoding, probability
is indicated in grayscale.
So you can see here
the dark areas,
this is high probability
that this pattern--
the animal would have
been in this location,
or to get this
pattern of activity
in this 20 millisecond bin.
And so, what you can see
here is that the probability,
these Bayesian
decoded probabilities,
form short sequences
every single theta cycle,
what we refer to
as theta sequences.
And the theta sequences
actually move from just
behind the animal--
dotted line is where
the animal actually is.
The estimate goes from just
behind the animal to just
in front of the animal.
So 10 times a second
the hippocampus
is actually expressing
a representation
of spatial sequence
that goes from behind
to in front of the animal.
You can think of
behind and in front
as also reflecting recent
past and near future.
So there is this relative
predictive differentiation
of response as a function
of oscillatory phase.
So if I want to look at, "Gee,
where did I just come from?"
I just have to look
at activity here,
at this slightly earlier phase.
If I want to ask the question,
"Gee, where am I likely to go
to?"
I simply have to shift the
phase, the channel that I
look at here, and
I can see where
the likely future location is.
So you can think that
there is actually a code,
not just of location, but of
the relative causal relationship
between locations
mapped into phase.
And we'll see that
we can experimentally
test this idea,
that that's just not
an artifact of our decoding,
but the animals are actually
using information of
these different phases
to drive spatial navigation
in particular ways
by using some of the tools
for manipulating activity
in a closed loop optogenetics.
So we see we can manipulate
activity, specifically
manipulate activity, hippocampal
activity, different phases
and show these different
phases actually
carry different
functional consequences.
So we've got these sequences.
So we've got these
sequences captured
during these oscillations.
Are these things
actually meaningful?
Well, some of the
indications that,
A, the oscillations in the
sequences are meaningful
first come from the observation
that, as I mentioned,
actually successful,
using memory--
information that the hippocampus
requires that you actually
communicate this to
executive structures
that can guide behavior,
make decisions.
That would include
the prefrontal cortex.
The portion of the
prefrontal cortex,
which form part of
this limbic circuit,
referred to as the
limbic prefrontal cortex,
which have direct connections
from the hippocampus.
These structures are--
in the hippocampus,
you have deficits in
spatial learning memory.
Prefrontal cortex-- you
think of this as deficits
in working memory and
retrieval, executive control,
decision-making.
But you can think of these two
things as working together.
Hippocampus
providing information
that the prefrontal cortex can
use in order to direct behavior
and decision-making.
And you damage either one
of these things, animals,
rats can't find their
way around the space.
You damage either one
of these in humans,
you're going to get
memory deficits.
Dementia is-- when you think
of dementia as being problems
of cognition and memory, you
can get them temporal lobe
dementias, frontal lobe
dementias, you can have--
they're really very
closely related.
And so we can look
at a simple task.
This is a simple task, testing
a so-called working memory.
Just remember, what
did you do last?
And this task, it's just
a simple alternation,
where you turn left--
first time you turn left,
next time to go right.
Ethologically, it's
like, "Look, I just
got food over here, why don't
I check out the other place?
I'll check out places
where I didn't get food."
It's a so-called
win-shift strategy.
I got something here this time,
I'm going to go someplace else.
As opposed to-- a
reference memory strategy
would be referred
to as a win-stay.
That's really a good spot.
Home.
I love going home because I've
got my TV, I got my microwave,
I'm going to stick
with that place.
Win-stay, you keep going back
to the place that rewards you.
And so you can think of both--
again, both of these things
have ethological value.
Home is a good place,
that's a reference place.
If you're foraging,
win-shift, don't go back
to the place I
just looted, right?
Again, these two structures--
classically, you think of--
in the prefrontal cortex we
think of working memory cells.
And this is the short term,
the idea of short term memory.
So prefrontal
cortex typically has
been thought of as subservient.
Working memory,
where working memory
is about holding information
over short delays.
It's an overlap in
terminology, where
working memory in
the prefrontal cortex
is really thinking about time.
Working memory in
hippocampus is really
thinking about the context
in which it's used,
relative, session specific
information, trial
specific information.
So I'm not going to go
through the details.
You have these two systems.
One interesting property, if
you look at these two systems
simultaneously, what you
find is that the same idea
about oscillatory phase
governing the firing of cells
in the hippocampus also applies
in the prefrontal cortex.
That is, cells in
the prefrontal cortex
like to fire at a certain
phase of the hippocampal theta
rhythm.
They care about,
their listening to,
this rhythm in the hippocampus.
And so, we can look at a task.
This is basically the
same kind of task,
only now there's a
back-to-back T-maze.
So there can be two
T-mazes, and we're just
going to do a simple
variation on that,
on that working memory
task, in which the animal's
going to start from
one of these two
arms-- it's going to
walk down this arm
and then, it has to go to the
arm that's on the same side
as it started from.
So it has to remember,
"Where did I start from?
Oh, that's the side
I have to go to."
Then it's going to
turn around, it's
going to come back,
run down here,
and then, we're going to force
it into one of these arms.
So two back-to-back T-mazes.
In this direction, the animal
chooses, in this direction,
we choose.
In this direction, there's
a working memory demand.
It has to remember
where it came from.
In this direction, doesn't
have to remember anything,
doesn't make any difference.
So behaviorally, it's symmetric,
but cognitively, here there's
a working memory demand,
here there's not.
And then we're going to look at
all these things, oscillations,
spiking, and the oscillations,
look at the peak time,
look at the firing with
respect to that, firing,
spiking, as a function of this
oscillation in both structures.
The bottom line is
what you find is,
that this is a measure
of relative phase locking
and as how well do
prefrontal cells actually
lock to this data oscillation.
And what you find is that the
degree to which they locked
the theta rhythm is a function
of whether or not the animal
has to choose.
So the red ones are when the
animal's going down the arm
and it's got to choose.
The gray one is when it doesn't
have to choose, when we choose.
Then in addition,
the solid red is
when the animal had to
choose and it got it right.
And the stipple red is
when it had to choose
and it got it wrong.
So the degree to which the
prefrontal cortex actually
locks, successfully locks, to
the hippocampal theta rhythm,
predicts whether the
animal actually makes
the correct choice or not.
So it's as though
this is a channel that
is necessary for effectively
communicating information
between the two structures.
And, that not only is it in
the blocking of the spikes,
spikes in the prefrontal cortex,
the rhythm in the hippocampus,
it also comes in the blocking
of the rhythms themselves.
So you can think
of there being--
this is the theta
rhythm that you
can detect in the prefrontal
cortex and in the hippocampus.
And what you can see is
there are two conditions.
One, the animal's actually
choosing, is running down here,
it's making a choice.
And in about the half second
before the animal makes
a choice, you see these
two rhythms actually
lock, they become coherent.
So transient coherence
is predictive
of correct choice behavior.
The thinking is that
the rhythms themselves
can be generating coordinated
through the regulation
of these local
inhibitory circuits.
In fact, there's been a lot
of interest, for instance,
in the relationship
of local inhibitory
control and neuropsychiatric
disease and disorders.
So, for instance, disrupting
local inhibitory rhythms.
In particular,
some, for instance,
the theta rhythms
in prefrontal cortex
can be associated with
disorders like schizophrenia,
for instance.
So the inability to
effectively impose these modes
and then synchronize these
modes can introduce disruptions
in the ability to
communicate or use memory.
Cognitive disruption
coming through disruption
of these oscillations through
disruption of inhibition
in these local circuits.
Now how you actually coordinate
these two subjective states.
We've been looking at the role
of mid-line thalamic nuclei.
So the thalamus as being
a set of structures
that have widespread
connectivity to all
these cortical areas, that
much of their connectivity
is inhibitory, and so they
have the ability to actually
coordinate, modulate and
coordinate, these oscillatory
modes.
We've even just recently
published on individual cells
we found in some of these
mid-line thalamic nuclei
that, for instance, will branch.
Single cells will
branch and target cells
in the hippocampus and
the prefrontal cortex.
So they would be
ideally positioned
to introduce, to
select and impose,
this synchronization there.
So that's the way
we think about a lot
of this dynamic connectivity
being established,
presumably through some
sort of thalamic regulation.
And then, you think
about the thalamus
as being regulated by those
so-called thalamic reticular
nucleus that
regulates the thalamus
and it sets up these modes.
And there's also
a lot of interest
now in the thalamic
reticular nucleus
in disease and disorders.
A lot of the genetic
screening has
identified targets in the
thalamic reticular nucleus.
So you can think about it again.
It's like the oscillator in
your computer or your radio that
breaks down, you can't--
the information can be there,
but you can't tune into it.
So it's this fundamental tuning.
You've got to have
the modes and you've
got to be able to lock
to these frequencies.
And then, beyond
that, as we'll see,
it's not just the
frequencies, but it's also
the precise phase within
those oscillatory modes that
carry different information.
That we actually determine
by taking advantage
of these techniques,
optogenetic techniques,
for targeted manipulation.
So you infect the
inhibitory neurons
in the hippocampus with
this optogenetically
encoded and controllable
channel so that we can optically
excite inhibitory cells.
So we infect this excitatory
channel into inhibitory cells,
and then, we can transiently,
giving very brief pulses
of laser light, we can activate
drive, inhibitory cells,
and then, because
the local circuit,
those inhibitory cells will
inhibit the excitatory cells.
And so we have about
20-25 millisecond control.
And now, we can
lock, or control,
inhibition based upon the
phase of this oscillation.
So the idea is, we're
going to selectively
disrupt, or inactivate,
the hippocampus
at different phases.
We're going to ask,
"Do those phases,
do they differ in terms
of their contribution
to behavior and performance?"
So here, we're going
to lock inhibition
to either the peak of the trough
of this state of oscillation.
And so in this task--
and we're going to do this
manipulation, that is,
selectively inhibit--
you're picking
hippocampal output
at either the peak of the
trough, the theta rhythm,
at two behavioral phases.
So in this task, animal's going
to start on one of these arms,
going to run up, and
it's going to choose.
So we're going to think
about the starting arms as--
we'll refer to this
as the encoding phase.
This is where you have to
keep track of where you are.
And then, here in
the central arm--
we'll refer to this as
the retrieval phase.
This is where you
have to remember,
"Oh, where did I come from?"
And then use that to decide
where you're going to go to.
And what we found was
pretty surprising.
And that is that, you
might think, well,
if you shut off hippocampal
output, turn off
the hippocampus, you're
going to get an impairment.
It's just like in
the examples that I
gave of suggesting
hippocampal's prefrontal cortex.
Most of those come
from lesion studies.
You damage the
hippocampus, the animal
can't find its way around.
So if you were to optogentically
lesion, or turn off
the hippocampus,
you might imagine,
OK, animals won't be able
to find a way around.
So you could ask,
"This experiment
is going to identify which
phase, which behavioral phase,
are most effective in
disrupting performance?"
But what we actually found
was, when you selectively
inhibit activity at
different phases,
you actually get an
enhancement of performance.
They get better.
And it depended--
there wasn't just
one phase, a good
phase and a bad phase,
but both at the
peak and the trough
were both effective in
enhancing performance,
but only when applied at
certain behavioral phases.
In fact, there was this
double dissociation.
And that is, that
trough stimulation,
when applied here--
so when you stimulate
in the trough,
in the retrieval segment,
animals got better.
When you stimulate at the
peak, in the encoding segment,
animals got better.
So it wasn't that the peak is
good or the trough as good,
it's the peak.
The peak is good
during retrieval
and the trough is
good during encoding.
So what it says is,
the peak and the trough
had two different functions.
And if you actually think about
what I was showing before,
these sequences,
these sequences that
are going from just behind to
just in front of the animal.
What it says is, oh yeah,
these different phases, peak
and trough, you can think
of as like past and future.
And so if I'm sitting over here
in this encoding segment, what
I'm really trying
to do is I'm just
trying to keep track of
where am I right now.
Now, I may simultaneously
also be thinking about, oh,
where am I going to go?
But for this task, it's
not really helpful.
It's not really useful.
At this point, I need to
focus on where I am right now.
So you can think
of simultaneously,
the actions of
these two channels,
where am I, where
am I going to go.
And I can enhance performance
by shutting off or inhibiting
the non-relevant one.
So when I shut off the retrieval
channel here in the encoding,
I get better.
It's like focusing attention.
It's like, pay attention
to what you're doing now.
Stop thinking about stuff.
Similarly, when I'm here
in the retrieval segment,
I'm also encoding.
I'm trying to keep track of
where I am as well as, think
about where I'm going to.
The thing is, keeping
track of where I am here,
it's not relevant for the task.
It might be broadly
relevant for the animal,
but it's not relevant
for the task.
So when I shut off, I turn
off that encoding channel,
I'm able to enhance the
retrieval information that
goes out.
You might interpret
this saying, "Oh,
so this is how we can improve
memory by selectively shutting
off the hippocampus."
Well, this is not a strategy for
general cognitive enhancement.
Hippocampus is working much
better when all these phases
are in operation.
And that's because
the hippocampus is not
designed to solve this task.
Hippocampus is designed
to solve the broader task.
It's trying to figure out how
is this task relevant to all
the other things
that I have to do?
In other words, you're trying
to integrate this information
into all the other
information you have.
And that requires connecting
the encoding or retrieval.
You really need to have all
of those pieces of information
available.
But it does point out
that one can actually
dissociate the
function of information
of these two different phases.
The phase actually matters.
And it matters at the
level of high level
behavior, decision-making.
It's not just a idiosyncrasy
or artifact of--
excitability is a
function of phase.
This is really how
information is being used.
Sources of content the
respective copyright
holders, all rights reserved,
excluded from our Creative
Commons license.
For more information, see
http://ocw.mit.edu/fairuse.
Sources of content
used with permission:
Rat brain, hippocampus
EEG, theta sequences,
bar/raster plot, courtesy
of Elsevier, Inc.,
http://www.sciencedirect.com.
Hippocampus electrode,
courtesy of Plos.
Hippocampus optogenetics,
courtesy of eLife.
License CC by 4.0.